thanks Moses for Prince Harry's first
interview after welcoming his baby boy
is the cutest thing you'll see all day
yes I'm very excited to announce that
baby boy early this morning a very
healthy boy mother and baby are doing
incredibly well it's been the most
amazing experience I can ever the 34
year old new Papa spoke to reporters
shortly after making Markel gave birth
to their 7-pound 3-ounce son and he was
absolutely beaming as he praised his
wife how any woman does what they do is
beyond comprehension but we're both
absolutely thrilled and so grateful to
all the love and support for everybody
out there but there's one piece of
information the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex aren't sharing just yet
so think about names Alan it's the
babies a little bit overdue so we've had
a little bit of time to think about it
but now Harry and Megan opted to
announce the arrival of baby Sussex in
their own way rather than the
traditional post baby photo up on the
Lindo wing steps at st. Mary's Hospital
the couple will celebrate as a family
before giving us our first look I think
we'll be seeing you guys in probably two
days time as planned as a family to be
able to share it with you guys and so
everyone can see the baby we can't wait
to see what this little guy looks like
but in the meantime we'll settle for our
favorite ginger gushing about his new
fam I haven't been in many books this is
definitely my first but there's amazing
absolutely incredible and as I said I'm
so incredibly proud of my wife and as
every father and parent would ever say
you know your your baby is absolutely
amazing but this little thing is
absolutely delightful as for how
everything went down early Monday
morning Buckingham Palace announced that
Meghan was in labor
and shortly after the Sussex duo's
Instagram account revealed that the
tiniest royal was safely delivered
congratulations to Harry and Megan on
their newest addition I never thought my
life would be that awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]